at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I also question now -
etiquette is over
[Music]
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
peloton which I've been using probably
for about a year now peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you can also do on-demand
which is what I do we'll come back to
that so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or
making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute I for
instance have a peloton bike right in my
master bedroom at home and it's one of
the first things I do many mornings I
wake up I meditate for a bit then I
knock out a short 20 minute ride in my
undies hard to do that at the gym take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's really convenient
and has become something that I look
forward to so you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride live
with thousands of other riders across
the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite liked mat wolbers and I tend to
do on-demand and listen to a lot of and
watch many of the same classes over and
over but I'm kind of promiscuous and
also enjoy classes from a lot of the
other instructors they have peloton an
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right
gamification yadda yadda yadda I didn't
think that it would work for me or in
any way and sent avise me but they
really 100% hit the nail on the head I
was very very impressed with how
motivating it was
and work tremendously to keep me pushing
which quite honestly takes a fair amount
I can get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me
so check it out discover this cutting
edge indoor cycling bike that brings a
studio experience right to your home
peloton is offering listeners of this
podcast a limited time offer
go to one peloton calm that's o-n-e
peloton PE l oto and.com and enter the
code Tim all caps at checkout and get
$100 off of accessories with your polish
on bike purchase so get a great workout
at home anytime you want check it out go
to one peloton calm and use the code Tim
to get started this episode is brought
to you by Charlotte's Web which makes a
CBD oil a hemp extract that has become
one of my go-to tools now I have never
really talked about CBD oil and cannabis
has never really been the plant for me
and over talking about him but
nonetheless after several nights of
inexplicable insomnia this is about a
year ago I just could not get to sleep
saved my life and after other fixes
failed so melatonin California Poppy
extract da-da-da-da-da an elite athlete
introduced me to this non psychoactive
extract and BAM
problem solved I had some of the best
sleep that I'd had in months now I don't
use sleep aids on a daily basis but this
has become part of my toolkit and I hope
to be exploring other applications soon
CBD oil products have exploded in
popularity in the health and wellness
and fitness worlds and Charlotte's Web
is one of the top players that offers
broad spectrum hemp extract with CBD in
the form of oils capsules and topical
products Charlotte's Web products will
not get you high so that maybe that is
good news maybe bad news to you but it
does have some powerful benefits and
applications and it works with your
body's existing endocannabinoid system
endo meaning from within like endo
versus exoskeleton for instance so
endocannabinoid system works with your
body some of the most common uses are
for relief from everyday stressors
in supporting restful sleep which is
what I most often use it for to bring
about a sense of calm and focus a lot of
my friends use it for that CBD is also
known or becoming known for helping
athletes to recover from
exercise-induced inflammation
Charlotte's Web
hemp extract has naturally-occurring
terpenes flavonoids and other valuable
hemp compounds that work synergistically
to heighten positive effects sometimes
referred to as the entourage effect
which you guys can look up making it
more complete than a single compound CBD
alternatives or at least that is what
I've been told I do not know much about
CBD alternatives North single compound
in any case check it out this stuff has
really worked for me to jump over to CW
hemp dot-com forward slash Tim CW is in
Charlotte's Web CW hemp comm forward
slash Tim to take a quick quiz which
will determine the best product for your
particular Ames lifestyle etc and they
ship to all 50 states Charlotte's Web
are offering listeners of this podcast
10% off of their purchase well there are
some exclusions I personally use the
extra strength CBD oils or the extra
strength capsules and you can see what
might be a fit for you on that page and
there is a 30-day risk free guarantee so
why not try it out
so get 10% off of your purchase at CW
hemp com forward slash Tim and
disclaimer these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration this product is not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease enjoy
hello ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show and this episode
is a case study episode the most
requested type of episode that I have
been somewhat negligent in providing and
today we have three folks with me two
co-founders and then Elaine Poe felled
and Elaine it's nice to have you back on
the show and could you perhaps just
describe for a moment aside from being
very accomplished journalist you are an
author and what what what book of yours
is most relevant to the conversation
we're going to be having well there's
only one book so far it's the million
dollar one-person business and what it
looks at is how non-employer businesses
those with no employees except for the
owners are scaling to 1 million dollars
in revenue and beyond and it's great to
be here Tim it's it's a subject that is
endlessly fascinating to me and to many
of my listeners one they wish I would
explore more so here we are and I've two
young gentlemen across from me I don't
know them that well so they may not be
gentlemen but I suspect they are very
well but well they we have we have
Benedict dolmen and Santiago miss status
both 21 is that currently the case great
21 so well aged silver foxes they met as
computer science students at Dartmouth
College I've heard of that school very
good very very good institution and they
worked very long hours in the library
both of them suffering from back pain
this is this is relevant because they
began collaborating on a prototype for a
product the end up being called the
supporter back and in the process of
developing it gathered a lot of feedback
from members of the Dartmouth community
including a local hospital president and
professors as well as students studying
engineering and medicine so we will
revisit a lot of what we're discussing
in this little intro slash summary they
also experimented with pay-per-click
marketing set up a system for testing
and tracking keywords using Excel
spreadsheets or spreadsheets they
launched the product first on Amazon in
the UK and Benedict Ben who is from
Germany is Floyd mish transferred to
Cambridge University to be close to his
family Santi
is based where we're recording this
right now which is Austin Texas and when
it seemed their first small order was in
danger of selling out this I definitely
want to talk about they arranged
financing from their supplier and were
off and running they've since entered
the US market on Amazon and this year
they're on track for eight figure
revenue that means this year 2018 next
year on track for nine figure revenue
and they are in the process of
introducing more than 120 consumer
products which range across many many
different categories including beauty
skincare pet supplies baby supplies food
and nutrition and in a sense I hope we
will have time to get to this maybe
that'll be around two but I think we can
get into it they are hoping to become an
alternative to very large consumer
products companies through a strategy of
applying their scale-up strategies that
they have tested successfully themselves
to brands they acquire so that's a
mouthful but I think it gives a nice
overview of the landscape then and
santhi welcome to the show thank you
thank you for having us and I thought
maybe I'll let you kick this one off
sure that sounds great well Ben and
Santi one of the things I loved about
your story so much was the wonderful
friendship that you have tell us how
that came to be yes sure
so we met originally at Dartmouth
College we are studying computer science
kind of nerdy coders up until the
library doing our labs our classes we
met we are one of the last few guys in
the library and it so happens that at
those hours you do eventually approach
the other people around and then see
what they're working on what their
struggles aren't also helping each other
out so that's originally how we got got
close and yeah just it really kicked off
from there so how did you find out you
both had back pain his answer if you
needed my help a bit in the lab so I was
always helping him out and that's why
so I mean inevitably when you're when
you're over the computer you know you
don't have the best posture and and we
started getting a bit of back pain that
developed over time especially when it
gets to 3:00 4:00 a.m. so so he took the
really nerdy approach of trying to
figure out why is this happening to us
back bend seemed like something that
only happened to really old people so so
we started geeking out and reading
research luckily we had access to the
Dartmouth Hitchcock hospital we just
renowned in back pain and started
learning more about it and discovered
that posture was the core driver for
back pain and it's something that a lot
of Americans are suffering when people
around the world because our bodies are
simply not designed to be sitting down
especially hundred over a computer all
day yeah especially given the the new
phrase sitting is the new smoking that
was kind of the guideline they're good
my claim my friend Kelly Starrett
would agree he may have even come up
with that phrase I'm not sure where it
originated how do you guys then go from
complaining about a common problem and
doing some homework on it and research
to considering creating a product or
starting a company right because I'm
sure especially in this day and age you
guys met how long ago about four years
ago no and a half two and a half years
ago two and a half three years ago that
yeah there are lots of folks now hoping
to learn to code or hoping to learn
computer science because it has been
become very clear that that is an
enormous asset and entrepreneurship so I
think there are more entrepreneurs than
ever with in CS departments but at what
point did you guys decide that this is
something you might consider as a
business well we we initially developed
the product mostly for ourselves we
started looking at what products were
out there that we're already working big
believer that you don't have to reinvent
the wheel just make it slightly better
so we took products out there started
tweaking with them initially just for
our own use so we were we're not trying
to make it at commercial it was not in
our heads eventually so we came up with
our two versions one so you were buying
off the shelf and then modifying them
the combination of many things so we
brought up on its discarded like 95%
the few that worked and we started
tweaking them and making them better
adding padding we're not engineers but
we were trying to figure it out just to
increase our it's called proper
reception is basically our awareness of
a back pay of poor posture that was
leading to back pain and made our two
versions one for Ben and one for myself
and with time we started seeing that our
friends
we're also young which we did not expect
to also have a bit of back pain they
were also coming to us and saying hey
you know I'm pulling an all-nighter
tonight can I use your your product or
hey I'm gonna go on a trip to New York
can I take the product with me so that's
when we we took a step back and said
look there's clearly a need for it we
don't know how we're gonna sell it or
commercialize it but let's just let's
just sort of like the burn the ship's
approach and let's just make an order
and then we'll feel we'll figure out how
we're gonna sell it once once they land
so that's how the first order came about
it's a bit of a story behind it and I
think there's also where what you just
mentioned the computer science
background especially is a hotbed or a
breeding ground for a lot of modern-day
entrepreneurs now this is a physical
product right so it's not a software
then you're movin moving atoms around
but we we see computer science as a tool
a tool kit or a toolset that enables us
to enhance our products per se in the
physical products so it's definitely
varied we've seen a lot of value in
having that as our background yeah
you said there's a bit of a story behind
that first order well let's talk about
its I mean how much money did you see
how much money do you guys spend on that
first order and where did it come from
why did you have the confidence yeah it
was under it was under $2,000 that was
our whole budget we would put together
or savings here and there as college
students and so he started figuring out
like 44 are things even made we didn't
had no idea so we figured out China was
a main player especially when it comes
to physical products and started
learning how Alibaba was a great catalog
for a lot of suppliers not necessarily
the part that we wanted to make because
it didn't exist we were trying to make
it differently but you could see through
by seeing other similar products who
were the key manufacturers out there in
China but obviously with $2,000 you
can't get really far when it comes to
manufacturing a really big order but I
refused we refused to take the approach
of like we need an investor and take
that as an excuse not to not to move
forward so we we made up this whole
story that we were a massive company out
of Boston and we had a big board meeting
coming up and and and we had over a
hundred board members that we wanted to
distribute samples to so that they would
decide together if we're gonna place the
big order and the big order was gonna be
like million million plus dollars but
bear with me we only have two thousand
right now for this so they I don't know
if they believe they're not today they
did they saw something in it and they
they said look let's go with it I'm sure
the margins were worked great for them
for that for those two thousand but uh
that's how the first 100 units came
about they put it on the ship and send
it and then we said nope now we have 30
days to figure out how are we gonna sell
it for that was a story netted the
reason you have 30 days because it was
net 30 terms for payment or did you set
that for yourselves as a deadline so so
the first order wasn't there was no
there was no terms yet that's of yet um
it was just 30 days that I took to ship
via CIC to get it over on the containers
or whatever yeah was gonna take 30 days
so what did you guys what were you
hatching at that time so been maybe take
a stab at this like a hat you were I'm
sure starting to think about how you
might sell these things were there any
resources websites books or anything
that you guys were using to try to
educate yourselves on entrepreneurship
marketing sales anything at all
absolutely and at that point we we had
the time went over around 30 days to
figure out how would we sell these first
quote-unquote sample units we delved
into first of all researching what
distribution channels were out there
looking at retail on and especially
online e-commerce distribution channels
such as Amazon Shopify Walmart I mean
there's a whole range we are big
believers in focus so
finding one solution and then sticking
with that until it works even though
there might be roadblocks on the way and
so what we did was we spoke to some
people some actually some friends of
ours who had sold a resold
a product on Amazon and I think eBay
before they showed us some basic basic
marketing approaches or tactics relevant
to Amazon and eBay and when we decided
to go with Amazon and test that out and
see if it works for our products because
obviously there's also a certain
dependency some channels work better for
other products etc with that as a
starting ground we then had to figure
out okay let's use this as a base but
how do we actually market our product
specifically on Amazon now that entailed
multiple parts just basic marketing
principles essentially part of that was
figuring out the copywriting so we read
I personally read around four books on
copywriting within those 30 days I took
around a 2-day deep dive in copywriting
101 taught by myself that was reading
the boron letters by by borin how do you
spell B o R oh and the boron letters
boron that is very good any other books
you remember yeah there is another one
called cash realizing cash for ties yes
which was very helpful recommended so
multiple and then I synthesized all the
tactics or all the learnings from those
books into one big notes document came
up essentially with a 20 step sales
letter formula synthesizing the
different advices from the different
books and also blocks on top of that
your copy algorithm essentially yes and
then try to apply that to the Amazon
sales page do you recall what some of
the steps were at this point that's been
a long time ago I can tell you that the
key principles which have benefited as
most in terms of copywriting and sales
have been focusing on the
benefits rather than the features a lot
of mistakes we see being made or an
incorrect approaches people often take
is they focus on the features of the
products but what consumers our
customers actually care about is what
what benefits them ultimately so
constantly focusing on that is kind of
the 80/20 or like the one thing -
copywriting as the main guiding
principle let's makes me think of the
iPod which for for those of you who
weren't born in the dinosaur ages the
iPod was this device about the size of a
brick initially that played songs no
telephone and it was not the first mp3
player that you could put in your pocket
but it was arguably the first - instead
of describing and selling the product in
terms of the number of gigabytes it
could hold and on technical specs said
something and I might begin this
slightly off but a thousand songs in
your pocket right and making the
connection much more clear between the
purchase and the benefits that you
derive from it okay so you guys are are
figuring out copywriting how are you at
this point at all in the beginning
separating responsibilities or
investigating different things or are
you guys all doing everything at that
point if 30 days before these air-quote
sample products arrive how are you
thinking of of partnering on this
because you don't want to duplicate each
other's effort constantly because that's
redundant and would seem to be
particularly abhorrent to computer
science students so how are you thinking
about working together I would have
planted uh-huh it was it was more like
we're all in this same boat together
let's see how we can get there faster
now I think it's more we've divided that
and compr mentalize that it'll be better
I did gravitate a bit more towards the
keyword science behind it and and Ben
was more around
copywriting in sales science behind it
we took the same approach that
everything is how can we make a formula
for it to work every time right um so I
took a bit more the the pay-per-click
approach to it so started understanding
how did keyword based algorithms work on
platforms like Amazon and and why were
certain products displayed how did you
figure that up um well if someone came
to me and said I want to figure that out
what would your advice be the first
thing I would say is go go understand
the basics because it actually takes a
while um it took me it took a while for
me to understand what a keyword based
algorithm like what a keyword based
search is and how long tail keywords are
different than short tail keywords on
different types of matches so I looked
at a course by Brian Johnson it's really
it starts from the basics and it's a
deep dive into what PPC is specifically
on Amazon and then once you understand
that what we realized is a lot of those
people were they really had no
statistical backing to a lot of the
methods that they were using to optimize
their word good rule of thumbs but they
would not necessarily the best so we to
get an edge on that market and to get an
edge on on the keywords that we're
bidding and to understand what truly are
the keywords that we want to go after
that are most likely to convert to our
product we started developing an
algorithm or a simple formula as to what
was the right bid for that specific
keyword and that was all based on when
is it statistically significant to
discard a keyword whether it's to keep
bidding or to adjust that bid correct
you did this all on Excel spreadsheet
with the time yes so a lot of people
think when they hear formulas algorithm
so you can even name it AI because I
thought is they name a lot of things
they I don't forget deep learning simple
formula you can accelerate deep learning
it was all run on Excel sheets and then
that's when we said look and we I think
we got a big edge and that helped us
kickstart I give that initial momentum
to those hundred units that we had that
then we started to show up organically
on des so these these hundred units
arrive right just describe the day so
you guys are doing all this homework
yeah describe the day when this stuff
lands but didn't even see it so it went
straight from from from China to our
fulfillment Network we leveraged Amazon
Fulfillment FBA yeah I'm as a
fulfillment partner they're the most
efficient we found and yet to this day
we still use them we never saw that the
products then we did we did get some
samples to do some quality control but
we'd really didn't see the whole
shipment it was very abstract to us
right um you think about a hundred units
and you actually don't even know how it
looks and still they're probably better
for you guys in some ways it was
probably better yeah
so they arrived and I remember I was I
was actually I was actually just sitting
down at home I was I was back back with
my family and I think Ben was also back
in Germany with his family yeah and we I
just looked up in the phone from from an
hour to the next no we saw it sold the
first day a quarter of our inventory so
that caught us off guard and that's when
we we said okay we're on to something
we've done something right and let's
figure out what is it that we did right
so we can do it over and over now were
you worried that you might just sell out
completely and I'll be able to fill the
orders we need we knew we knew we were
gonna sell out by that but the worry was
nothing compared to the excitement or
overwhelmed from actually having thought
to have found a formula for for some
sort of success in in that marketplace
what what did you do right when you look
back and what I'm also trying to just
see you guys have an idea of what I'm
gonna try to do in this interview there
are certain things that people have
trouble replicating if they don't have
certain types of training not
replicating isn't the right word
learning from right and then there are
other principles and so on that they can
borrow and apply and learn from that you
guys have used so I'll try to separate
those two a different points just
because not everyone coming in is going
to have the technical capabilities that
you guys have or the statistical
familiarity say but what what looking
back like what you guys do right so you
sold you said a quarter of your
inventory from one hour to the next
you're like on one hand you're like
high-five awesome and the other hand
oh [ __ ] okay this is this is turning out
differently than maybe we would have
expected good news but what did you do
right what did you guys do right so I
think I think what we did right after
after reflecting we still reflect on it
under today every every time we do a big
move we go back and think what did we do
right and wrong and constantly to learn
from our experience I think what we did
right then was take computer science
approach at developing the product it
all starts in the product you can have
amazing copy and you need to have
amazing copy and have amazing keyword
strategy and you need to have it but it
all boils down to the product cuz if you
have a good product it will convert best
and you really can outfit any competitor
in any keyword or any search ranking
also it's do returns customer service
issues all of that all of that it will
take care of itself if you start off
with having something good to offer but
obviously we were not back being experts
we still aren't and we're not experts in
the pet industry we're not experts in
the beauty industry what we did really
well was take the customer as the expert
don't take anyone else or anything else
as an expert but take the customer and
how can we apply what we've learned like
the Lean Startup methodology the ideal
method that a lot of software companies
used our methodology Eric Ries yeah yes
that that's cool very really really good
guy yeah so taking those that approach
that was so common in the software to
the product development is our only goal
at that point was let's hear what's
working out there is Hugh or it isn't
let's put those two things together
initially was for us eventually for the
market and then it was how can we get
those products on the ship as quickly as
we can so that we can start selling
because the day we start certainly is
the day we start learning day you start
getting feedback and this sometimes four
people are not familiar referred to as
the the MVP or yes exactly
I think it's minimal or minimally Viable
Product so how do you ship in mmm in the
context of Lean Startup very often
software which is very easy to iterate
physical products a little more
challenging but how can you get
something out into the real world with
real people who are not your friends
trying to tell you what you want to hear
so you can get feedback that can inform
better decisions yes and then a very
important concept we learned rip most
relevant that is there's a clear
distinction between feedback and failure
so usually what a lot of people react
say they ship out a product be the
software or a physical product whatever
into the market and they get zero sales
or they get very disappointed with very
very few sales a lot of people see that
as failure and decide to give up if you
take the MVP approach you see that as
feedback so with that feedback in hand
you can then cost correct and actually
identify the the triggers or the
variables that caused to the low sales
or that caused your miss of expectations
and then work on those and tweak them
and then iterate again
and ship out the next version or the
next product and see how that compares
to the previous version so I think that
that's for us that was very crucial to
understand the distinction between
feedback and failure failures when you
give up feedback is positive because it
allows you to iterate to get better
yeah and just having that mindset
creates a lens through which you look at
things very differently and it affects
the questions that you ask right so
before we start recording we were
chatting about podcasting a little bit
and the I want to say was like the first
or second question you guys hone in done
it's like how do you learn what's
working or not in the world of
podcasting which turns out to be
somewhat challenging from a technical
perspective given the lack of really
deep and specific analytics but that was
one of your very first questions and
it's it's if you do not have that
feedback oriented mindset it's very easy
whether something works or fails or
somewhere in between to just decide what
you're going to do next without looking
at what happened right and bit like
really spending time on the post game
analysis and figuring out like art is
this one off is it a problem that can we
replicate the problem right do we think
it's because the websites taking too
long to load I mean obviously it's
slightly different with Amazon but do we
think it's because the price is too high
you know is there a way not necessarily
Amazon where we can offer say an exit
pop-up that gives people a discount to
test that hypothesis right then your
your approach becomes very very
different
okay so you guys are launching your MVP
you've taken a Lean Startup / agile
development approach to product
development
you've now figured out what was the name
of that book cash cash verizon good so
terrible so bad it's good nationalizing
and what are you using to track your
sales at this point is there an Amazon
dashboard that you use to track that or
what are you watching yes we used so
Amazon has internal dashboards just in
the seller central which is the approach
we took where you can make an see basic
reporting on like sessions conversion
rate the overall sales as we grew we
then also expanded into third-party
software's though that give more a more
clear picture more organized more
structured because I especially in the
beginnings the Amazon's internal reports
and then their structure can be very
confusing and you can for pretty cheap
or I get a third party software that
shows you all the key metrics you
actually care about in a very clear and
structured format what are some of those
offers so we use one called SELEX SELEX
es e ll IX s e ll i CS o does that mean
it's not just a brand name or that's
their brand name okay we also use cash
go pro at one point zillion cash calpro
cash cow like cash cow business cash cow
yeah and then the cash capital they're
really really affordable um and it know
your metrics is really knowing your
metrics is really important so ya know
speaking as someone who is not sold
anything on
Amazon and looked at the UI or the
options for testing let's just say split
testing is it pot this is more for my
personal curiosity I'm sure there's
somebody out there wondering the same
thing
on Amazon can you test different price
points like automatically serve like
$29.99 to 30% of the audience and 1999
to 30th another 30% the audience and so
on and so forth
it's tricky overall from a high level
there are many different variables like
there might be a deal of the day running
or enlightening deal or or there's so
many variables it's very hard to control
for say price or for the images there
are certain tools out there who have
tried to give it some type of testing
there's one called split Lee let's SLP
yeah yeah split Lee what they do is they
subsequently test say image one against
image two or price point one against
price point two you can't do it
simultaneously so you can't do normal
a/b testing but it's a close closer
approximation and even within that the
price range where it very tactically on
Amazon you can't jump the price from say
1999 to 999 or especially the inverse so
you can't just drastically raise the
price because I'm as an Amazon will then
disallow you to own the buy box which is
a crucial part to your conversion rate
so there are certain intricacies but
some approximations as to get some rough
idea and some rough testing why did you
guys decide on on Amazon versus was it
primarily to simplify the fulfilled by
Amazon component of the entire process
or were there other reasons main Amazon
is of course a behemoth the outside of
well outside of China certainly in in
the United States highly dominant but
we're there were there other reasons you
guys chose Amazon as your as your
primary platform so
what we discovered again it's really
easy to for new new time entrepreneurs
to get caught up on reasons or or
complicating things and making it as
hard as possible to get to the ultimate
goal we just get to our customer we were
trying to get simplify everything down
to how can we get this product in front
of the right customer as quickly as we
can
an amazon offered the fulfillment side
which which pretty much removed all the
operation intricacies for us and it also
enabled us to go to the whole european
market as well without with the flip of
a switch sort of say and then
additionally it also simplified all the
marketing there's already active people
going into amazon trying to find
solutions for their problem
people that are problem aware or people
that are product aware there's people
going out this and i need a cushion for
my back or i need a pillow to sleep
better because i have back pain and
they're still looking to buy as opposed
to find information they have really
high by an intent so so instead of
figuring out how do we create awareness
how do we create product awareness and
eventually get those down the funnel
which which is a game or a science in it
of itself you're like all we have to
figure out is how do we convince those
that are already going into amazon that
look we are the best solution for them
and we truly believe in our products we
think they're they're better than the
ones out there so all we have to do is
demonstrate that um so that allowed us
to do it really really easily and amazon
additionally it's growing online is
growing over retail so it made the most
sense to us and still today we rely on
amazon as one of our main partners how
do you coming back to the MVP and
customer feedback get actionable
feedback so part of the reason i use
amazon as much as i do is to very
deliberately avoid interaction with many
merchants right i do not want to get
email i do not want to get
questionnaires i do now what if any more
interaction than absolutely necessary so
how do you guys get feedback on products
we aggregate a whole bunch of data and
that data comes from within amazon but
also off Amazon within Amazon
some of the main sections we look at our
reviews feedbacks competitors reviews
competitors feedbacks products in the
same industry or category their reviews
their feedbacks so feedback and reviews
from many post questions - because you
other questions and see what's confusing
people
that's another another way and then we
scrape all of that like we have bots
that aggregate that and put them into a
Google sheet essentially analyze it by
keyword frequency or some search query
frequency and then we try to see some
statistical trends as to alright this
complaints a with the memory foam this
complaint has come up X many times over
potentially that many purchases it's
roughly is statistically significant
this is something we should add to our
list to then implement in on our product
development on on the sourcing and
manufacturing side and then our familes
on as well I think looking at social
media engagement social media postings
et cetera aggregating all of that and
then combining that and synthesizing
with the on Amazon data to come up with
a list of features we can then implement
on the sourcing side and the way that
works is so we have this list of
features for every product that we would
like to implement which we where we see
from the real customers that they crave
or in some way desire that gives it's a
different story if people say okay this
pillow if you have two people saying
this is it's too firm for me and two
other people saying it's too soft
mm-hm that is in no way statistically
significant so we have this list of
suggestions and then we speak with our
manufacturers in China depending on on
where the products are sourced some
sourcing in the US and us all over we
speak with them to evaluate how the
feasibility of this feature of
incorporating that the costs of it
how fast can they turn it around will it
affect the lead times as to how fast
they're going to even produce then all
the subsidy
in batches and a whole bunch of smaller
smaller decisions if we decide to go
ahead and it makes sense from a
cost-benefit perspective we implement
that into the next cycle so the next
order we already have version n plus one
if we decide at this point it doesn't
make sense to implement that then we
keep it on our on a hold list and we
revisit and say three six nine orders
down the line we revisit ok does it make
sense now does it complement any of the
other features we've just incorporated
in in the past orders a judgment are the
and I don't know I don't know if this is
too much secret sauce discussion but now
let you decide
these are the when you say bots right
this is a word that gets thrown a lot
into media that people have seen and
it's I think generally poorly understood
right the the term scraping in BOTS and
so on are you guys using off have you
used off-the-shelf programs or services
for that are these things that you guys
have coded yourselves how does what does
that look like to answer your question
we've it's a great question by the way
we've we have computer science
backgrounds so we coded it ourselves and
like Python and some some libraries that
are out there anyone can use it's just a
way to automate it to auto automate the
process anyone can do this it's just it
will then require more manual work which
would otherwise be done buy it buy it
buy a script so anyone can go into 50
listings of competitor competitors
products look at their reviews
put them into an excel sheet and then
look over and and count the number of
words or the number of queries and then
map them out essentially these are the
queries we had 45 of them overall these
reviews etc yeah or just display as many
as possible than ctrl F and search for
whichever term right they show you right
at the top of the browser how many
occurrences that's how we did the first
time yeah yeah super simple yeah have
you found that the information you
gathered in the European market was
directly relevant to the US market are
there are there differences in terms of
the types of feedback that comes in did
you launch initially in Europe or yeah
okay yeah that's great that's a great
question so walk us through that yeah so
there are certain differences between
consumers in Europe and the US based on
what we've seen obviously our data set
is very limited based on on our on our
own products as well as our own personal
experience to give an example German
consumers I'm German myself tend to
focus more heavily on technical
technical aspects of the product shocker
the American direct response free to the
Germans it seems very salesy and very
off-putting
yeah and and similarly across even
within Europe you have the Germans you
have the French Spanish Italian very
different British they're all they all
have very different consumer behaviors
in a sense and so you have to cater say
the the copy and adjust it slightly to
teach what about the keywords we you
changed those also
well the keywords are independent of
that because the key word pillow for
instance house it's the same they're
generic sit exactly then the product
copy you used to convert them different
why did you choose to launch in outside
of the US first in the US would be more
uniform in the sense where it's like
okay yes people in New York are
different from people in Louisiana or
different from people in Nebraska kind
of but culturally they're probably going
to be closer or more similar than
Italians versus Germans right I would
think so
so back then it would have probably made
more sense to launch in the u.s. been
had German background we we believed
that we would have an edge at least with
the German marketplace
and I probably must have been at some
econ class and and taking some macro
parallels to it that nowadays I just
laugh at myself for it because it
doesn't really make a difference but
that it was mostly serendipity we
decided to go Europe we've discovered
some advantages in terms of their
stricter in terms of regulation so it
forced us to to put our parts through
regulatory processes that then are
really easy to go through once we bring
them into the US the market is
considerably smaller it's about three
times as small in terms of Amazon sizes
so it allowed us also to experiment and
get that feedback on a smaller sort of
sandbox and then once those products got
to the point where they were very
successful and most people were really
happy with them we flipped them over to
the US now that that is a very common
practice for a lot of big companies in
the sense that I believe Nike is one of
them that does a good amount of their
testing in New Zealand as they want to
test on a native english-speaking market
but if it is a catastrophic flop they
don't want it to be in Times Square or
necessarily in the larger playground or
sandbox of the u.s. let's say so do a
good amount of their research and
initial testing and iteration in a place
like New Zealand so let's that's
backtrack for a second look at the phone
OMG we've sold a quarter of our
inventory so I'm coming back to what I
said I would definitely come back to you
and here's the line when it seemed their
first small order was in danger of
selling how quickly I would say that the
story qualifies they arranged financing
from their supplier and we're off and
running walk us through that arranged
financing from their supplier this is
really important I think because and I
don't even know the story but most
people think and this is this is
particularly true I think in start-up
land where people hear the word startup
and if I think particularly for a lot of
people who are 20 22 year old however
old CS students like ooh go out venture
capital Sand Hill Road Silicon Valley
raise a bunch of money and they they
have that particular narrative when they
think of financing this is something
that is not that uncommon but it's
something very few people know about so
can you walk us through this yep
so from the get-go Ben and I we went in
with the mentality of removing obstacles
rather than and coming up with obstacles
and we would add what do you mean by
that so this is a great example is do
you need an investor to put your second
order otherwise you'll run out of stock
that is that is an obstacle that you
might actually be putting there by
yourself so we had this problem which
was we need to make a way bigger order
now we did have the profits from the
initial order we had a clear proof of
concept and we had heard this narrative
where you need investors to scale but we
said there must be a better way out
there this must be there must be a
quicker way out there so who do we went
to a biggest partner so far our company
that would thought we've heard massive
company out of Boston and said look
we're gonna place this bigger order but
as we are a big company we expect good
terms so we convinced them to give us a
good payment or what for those people
who are wondering what what are good
payment terms in this situation would
see what did you ask did you first did
you ask for specific terms or did you
say what are the best terms you can
offer what was the approach we came in
really demanding cuz we're a big company
out of Boston so we said look we're
gonna be placing a bigger order again we
we were pursuing the cash flow we were
pursuing profit we were not pursuing an
investor and have a tank and spend that
money and then figure out what we're
gonna do so at all points we're like we
we knew that we needed to be profitable
one the biggest issue with physical
products companies as today you have to
put the order that you gonna sell in
three months yes we have your sales are
up today and you expect them to be even
bigger and this problem we still
encounter on a day to day basis we're
gonna have to put in more capital today
to hopefully make up for the sales
tomorrow so we said okay they can be our
biggest partner came up to them and said
big companies like Walmart expects 60
day credit terms 100 net and they were
like no that's not happening
now explain for people what that means
they credit I mean it produced the whole
thing they said you the whole batch and
then 60 days after you get it you pay
for it
yeah then obviously they said no we went
back and what was the second part of the
terms so you said 100% so
something-something net 60-day 100
percent net Oh a hundred percent sorry
I'm just really
I got it yeah so we basically don't
don't put any penny penny upfront and
they send the whole thing and we pay
them 60 days after it right obviously
that didn't work out very well but it
but um the ultimate thing that we
understood both of us is that our
skilling obviously after the after that
point they started understanding we're
not that big company we're a small
company but we've been really successful
with that initial order and things came
down to down to earth but they
understood that we were a key player and
their scale and their scalability that
we're gonna grow with us as the same way
they're a big player in our scalability
so when you understand that you're both
trying to help each other and usually
the objections they have to giving you
credit terms it's not because they don't
want to is because they have risk
objections they also might be
cash-strapped so you you want to sit
down with them and have that honest
conversation and say look what guarantee
is gonna give you over this inventory or
what things can I do to easier cash flow
how can I guarantee that I'm gonna pay
this back in 30 days so I think we
managed to get somewhere near 50/50 or
or maybe was it was 70 it was 70 needed
to be paid by the time I left and the
other 30 needed to be paid sixty days
after and since then every time we go
back to the table and we always ask for
better terms as we continue to scale
every time you have a bigger order
that's a good opportunity to say look
can we get better payment terms to do
this bigger or I want to I want to
highlight something which is you didn't
assume well maybe did but you didn't
stop at the no you investigated the
fears behind the no this is really
important because there may be other
ways to address fears that do not
include paying for everything upfront
there may be other ways that you can
address it right and and that can range
from that not necessarily in this case
but getting a cosigner for a particular
deal so that worst case scenario they
have someone to hold financially
accountable who is
you write or ABCD write committing to
the next four orders in some type of
contractual way so that they they
mitigate the risk of getting burned on
one particular deal right there are many
different ways or maybe they say no
because they don't know who you are can
you provide them with references of some
type bool yeah allow them to sell their
supervisor on approving this because
they've only been in the job for thirty
days and they're not comfortable yet
taking the risk to approve that
particular deal there's a there's a
great book I would recommend to folks
called getting passed know which i think
is the more practical cousin of getting
to yes it's actually and it's actually
written
I think it's authored by one of the
co-authors of getting to yes did you
guys just figure out negotiating on the
fly or did you read anything related to
that or it was mostly on the fly who's
trying to put ourselves in the other
party's shoes and then making our
decision based on that mm-hmm so I guess
principles from game theory yeah we took
a class on at school yeah that helps a
lot all right so Helene feel free to
jump in at any time since you know you
were certainly more familiar with their
story then I am but you you are then
able to achieve what you set out to
achieve in a sense which is to get
favorable enough terms that you can get
more inventory yeah all right what
happens then so you've more product on
the way what what were some of the best
decisions that you guys made from that
point on like what were some of the
critical decisions right because a lot
of people try to sell products online
whether they're physical or digital and
most of them go into it unprepared most
of them do not learn from their mistakes
many of them do not apply any type of
rigor to their analytics or minding of
very basic things and that's keep in
mind coming from me and I am doubt as
innumerate as you can possibly be I'm
you know what I chose my university
based on a lack of math requirements or
not exactly a quant but very basic like
simple arithmetic and not fooling
yourself that like - customer reviews
that say X is cool means that
definitively across the board everyone
thinks X that's all you need right
really basic super basic so what you
guys have done very well you have a very
steep trajectory on sales you're
launching new products so you at this
point you have the support of a current
and you have more units coming in what
were some of the smartest decisions that
you guys made or worse decisions they're
both both are important in sort of the
months that followed one of the key
decisions and then Santiago you cannot
do that I'll dive into the first one was
to focus and we're big believers in the
Pareto principle in honing in on what's
working and keeping on that and getting
better that in not getting distracted
removing distractions and then you you
had mentioned to me your fins of the
4-hour workweek was that what made you
think along those lines absolutely I
mean Tim you mention it in the 4-hour
workweek focus and removing distractions
is definitely one in one of the key
decisions even if it was an unknown
decision so undone scene so to say
because you neglect something you you
don't see the thing you neglected so
what that meant and in this particular
case was we had many options to expand
into different channels say Walmart comm
jet comm even eBay where we could figure
it out but one of the key decisions we
did was to focus in and hone in on
Amazon in growing both our expertise as
well as our sales on that platform and
unknowingly one of the effects that had
is the way Amazon works from a very high
level is the more sales you have the
more sales you have so it's a snowball
or a cumulative advantage attribution
however you want to call it in that
Amazon ultimately cares about
transactions on their site so the more
transactions you have on their site
the more they like you and what the more
they like you means as they rank you
higher they give you access to
advertisement etc to a whole bunch of
other benefits based off of that so you
classified those other sites then as
distractions it sounds like yes and so
we were in Buffett and Charlie Munger a
big idols of ours and Warren Buffett
mentions one of his concepts remove in
distractions and focus is there are 20
things you want to do right now with
we're really burning to do say for us
that was expanding to other channels
like Walmart but you have to scrap them
all and focus on the one thing that
ultimately will push you forward and
real distractions are things you're
dying to do so we applied that in our
case and and kept on focusing on Amazon
I think that was crucial and there's one
of you rain the other end I mean there
is one of you better at narrowing the
focus or do you both do that for each
other it's both for each other and I
think there's a lot of value in a
partnership in particularly at that
point because one can easily lose
tracking and get distracted oneself but
having kind of it a second pair of eyes
is definitely where two plus two is way
greater than four in that sense you
mentioned you you guys have mentioned
well before we start recording and also
now Warren Buffett and Munger why are
the aside from yes they're very
successful investors that's that's great
and they're certainly among the best the
world has ever seen but beyond that or
maybe in addition to that like why are
these two so interested in do you guys
and when you say we idolize them that's
great but does that mean you study them
and if you study them how do you study
them that's a good question um we I
think what we admire the most out of
them is the ability to or the constant
pursuit of truth and rationality
how do we how do we really understand
the reality and keep emotion and
irrationality out of it as much as
possible they even admit there's no such
thing as perfection and that but they're
always striving to do that so the most
the most studying we do is both on what
they have to say I think our favorite
one of my favorite pieces of Charlie
Munger's speech in Harvard and I think
in nineteen you can look it up in
YouTube Charlie Munger Harvard yeah just
look up Charlie Munger commencement
commenced I think it's also in poor
Charlie's Almanac and in the newer
editions what they have to say pretty
much any insight into their lives I know
they're usually pretty private but um
there's this plenty of content out there
for free that you can you can you can
see but it's that pursuit of being
rational and staying on earth and
keeping emotions out of things that help
has helped us both in in prayer in our
personal lives and our relationship as
co-founders as in our ability to dissect
the business and focus on the few things
that actually move the needle then what
about you and as it relates to the that
dynamic duo are there any resources that
you would recommend or poor Charlie's
Almanac is definitely there I think
there's another book from Darwin to
Munger yep Peter beveling yeah seeking
wisdom I think is the title from Darwin
de Munger among Goethe Darwin is also
really good collection then the speeches
on YouTube and I think Munger has one at
USC yeah my second commencement speech
which is very valuable and I also would
recommend to folks who may not
explicitly have an interest in what you
think of as investing which is picking
stocks let's just stay to read the
annual letters to Berkshire Hathaway
shareholders by Buffett there are
collections of these letters and it will
help you to hone or at the very least
test your own thinking so that you
become clear or more clear about how you
are reaching your conclusions which yeah
translates to better investment of time
energy attention capital which is
certainly transfers to just about
everything all right so getting back to
the main story the the story line that
we've been we've been travelling along
here when did you begin to expand
outside of your first product and how
did you make how did you make that
decision so back to when I but I
mentioned that we took a time a pause to
understand what had worked
we understood again it was the approach
to product development
um how he took our CS background to
developing the best back pain product
and they said you know I'm gonna
interrupt you because I'm being a jerk
but also because I want to
we are gonna we're definitely going to
get to the expansion of product line but
I realized maybe we skipped a chapter
really early which was before you
ordered your product you were getting
feedback from people at Dartmouth what
did that look like this is really
hands-on it's something people can do
with communities around them how did you
elicit feedback in the very early days
because you guys are systems thinkers
right so you're not gonna be like hey do
you like it like ya like it you're like
okay great let's go buy a container full
product no you're not gonna do that so
what did you do look bad you know
limited feedback is better than no
feedback we took it with a big grain of
salt we went through we lined up a bunch
of people and say look we draw yourself
from the products as much as you can and
say what do you think of this use it for
a few hours we did a couple different
tests one of us like use it for a few
hours and and right before and we would
ask them how much pain are you in right
now and then how much pain are you in
after how statistically significant was
that or how valid it is probably isn't
very valid but then we reached out to
the CEO of the Dartmouth Hitchcock he
was nice enough he all his background is
on back pain it was nice enough to meet
with us and and give us his opinion on
his best practices but again that was
that was not the pillar or the core of
how the product was developed because
ultimately our biggest stuff for expert
is the customer and their behavior the
consumer behavior so we took that with a
bit of a grain of salt
took it as a guiding
but it was how can we get to the market
as quickly as we can and that's when the
true learning started mm-hmm
what were things that you modified in
the product I don't think we touched
upon this yet like so the supporter back
I mean you that was like your undergrad
and master's degrees setting you up for
the later products I would assume in a
lot of respects right so what were some
of the early changes that you made to
the product and that were important in
retrospect and why yeah so we actually
worked on on three products initially
they launched in a bit of a different
timing but the three were the brace the
the pillow and the lumbar support all of
those were supported back products I'll
give you the example of the of the
pillow because it's the most substantial
or clear changes that we did so we start
looking at again approach water what do
either peels are doing we knew that the
pillow let me backtrack so there's three
core points in your life where you're
what you have back pain or you're not
moving and when you're in poor posture
its when you're sleeping usually when
you're commuting in view commuted by car
like majority of the people in the US
and when you're sitting at work so our
customers kept coming back to us for
this kind of three products so what we
we set up we set off to do a pillow and
we understood started looking at
different types of pillows understood
that memory foam was the best material
again looking at the trends what what
mature has gotten the best feedback in
terms of solving the issue which is
mapping that was by four memory foam and
there were different densities of it so
that's when Ben came in and he was like
well but some people say too hard too
soft
what is them how can we pinpoint entity
and then and then start it once it
started suddenly we started getting
feedback from the customer saying clear
clear trend saying look the the memory
foam is great but it retains a lot of
heat and it's making our faces really
itchy but then two to three days we're
not really using the product I'm you
know throwing it to the side and using
my normal pillow so we were saying how
can we how can we make this cooler or
resolve this issue that there was
literally pillar literally cooler yeah
so we we started looking at other
industries and and how had memory so
from products before you're not trying
to reinvent the wheel just trying to
solve the issue the simplest way
possible found that the had a little
thin layer of cool gel on top and then
even pinpointed down to what both what
was the the the width of that layer how
how big would you want it to make it and
and added that specific layer to the
product make that change and within as
soon as that product hit the market it
became the best-selling pillow in all of
the UK marketplace it actually became
the best-selling pillow and all of whom
in kitchen as a category for a few days
how did you know about the materials
this seems like it would be totally
alien to most of us
we didn't so that was that was what we
did right the the the our own ignorance
pushed us to take the right approach and
is taking the customer has the ultimate
designer so we said look we don't know
what a memory foam is so let's buy all
the memory foam pillows and let's see
which ones have the best feedback on on
a specific memory foam as the enabler to
solve the problem so you looked at their
amp like your comments on Amazon about
those pillows it's wrongly extrapolated
an off Amazon again same approach to
iterating the same thing that we've done
right and then we literally took a
sample out of the memory foam send it to
our supplier and say can you make it out
of this memory from the examined it they
said this is the type of density this is
the color this is exactly how are we
gonna do it it was very systematic for
us if we couldn't do it again with any
product we will not even do it even if
we thought that we could input our own
opinions into it and make it different
we said that is not adorable let's not
do it that way question on manufacturer
I don't think I asked so there are a
million in one manufacturers out there
yeah and for everyone good story I hear
I hear 20 awful stories how did you end
up and you don't have to mention the
specific manufacturer but how did you
pick them and did you have to did you
make mistakes in the beginning and have
to replace your manufacturer how did you
go about vetting and selecting who you
ended up selecting so overall the
approach we took was let's put in the
upfront work in the vetting because
we'll make our lives down the line way
easier yep
instead of having to deal with a lot of
issues called the insurance etc so
Santiago already mentioned we initially
reached out via Alibaba to around again
very numeric driven approach to finding
a supplier for each culture I think
around 30 or 40 different suppliers all
within the categories of the products
through Alibaba I think we also looked
at 1688 comm which is a another
comparable site and within Alibaba you
also have certain metrics there's a gold
star rating there's metrics on how long
they've been on the platform for and
even Alibaba I guess given to their own
history has instituted quality checks
from within of their own people or
employees going to the factories taking
photos verifying all the certifications
are accurate etc so that was a good a
good ground basis to work off a lot of
the vetting came from speaking with the
the manufacturers themselves in how
professional they would behave and how
effectively they would communicate what
companies under nondisclosure but what
type of company is what size of
companies they'd work with in the past
example products they've worked and
produced themselves in the past so many
different variables we looked at to vet
them and ultimately like a checklist
where they had to take off different
different boxes what were some of the
questions you asked on the phone and at
what C 30 to 40 can reach out to how
many of those would you say you guys
called well we contacted all of them and
it's like a marketing funnel right yeah
yeah certain drop out and then we
obviously cut off a certain percentage
because it's a huge time investment on
our end to speak with 50 different
people simultaneously
so like we had an initial cut off in
terms of poor communication and that was
indicated by say poor English there some
certifications they could not hold up
etc well meaning they couldn't provide
certificates to show you exactly and
then so that was a big cut off then
another step in the funnel was actually
having a lawyer go over the
certifications and counter checking them
that they were accurate and not fake
there's basic services or basic lawyers
who can do that for a hundred two
hundred bucks so that was another stage
and how did you find the lawyers Google
search got it and those were based in
the US or based in Europe based in
Europe but the lawyer can be from
anywhere because these organizations are
global the certificate what do you
search on google for someone like that
what might you search yeah so it depends
again on the category of product you're
manufacturing a general good
certification to have is good
manufacturing practice GMP GMP so you
can look up for GMP certificate lawyer
approval verification etc he'll get it
home on very practical again and were
you going to your classes at this time
how did you actually find time to do all
of this yeah and that's a great question
going back to fara workweek that's
another point where that was very
influential to us because we had limited
time we obviously there was attendance
at class we had to do labs et cetera
which took up a lot of time so at the
time we had available we had to use very
focused like again Pareto principle
focusing on the few things that matter
and let me just pause you for one second
so Pareto principle for people who are
not familiar that term is often also
called the 80/20 principle and in very
very simple terms there's a lot of
nuance to it but you the idea or the
premise being it's more of a conceptual
framework but ends up manifesting
pretty accurately in a lot of different
areas whether it's agriculture or
looking at profit per customer or any no
headache per supplier that 80% of say in
the case of profit like 80% of the
profit that you generate will be
produced by 20% of your products 20% of
your customers and doing that type of
analysis to identify they're really
really good and also they're really
really bad so you can make more informed
decisions and 80/20 it doesn't mean it
doesn't have to add up to 100 it could
be the ninety five five principle where
five percent Ford is ninety five percent
of your headache with your accounts
receivable right I mean it could be any
number of things like that
but that's that's the named after
vilfredo pareto so sorry it's
interrupted yeah so you've got your labs
you've got your classes you have limited
time so you're really having to focus on
the things that that matter exactly and
the funny note we've actually seen
instances where people who dedicate full
time say to it to a business or to their
entrepreneurial pursuits end up being
less effective than people who are only
doing it part-time just because they get
distracted they get lost they don't use
their time effectively and ultimately
the people who say have a full-time job
or are in college can use the the
limited time they have available on the
things that matter again parallel
distribution and also use them
effectively focused not being on the
phone seeing all the messages from from
from the Y from the partner from from
work et cetera so I think again that we
use that from the for work week the
concept of focusing in on what matters
systematizing the rest and that's been
very very influential for us yeah it's
it's true for I mean a lot of folks
which is but in part why whether it's in
the 4-hour workweek or outside of that I
often talk about the 80/20 principle or
Pareto principle being used in tandem
with Parkinson's Law and Parkinson's Law
is a semi
it was initially written about in more
of a humorous satire like context but
the applications are really practical so
the the the premise of the Parkinson's
Law ha is that a task will will swell in
complexity fill the time that you allot
it and so the more time you have for
something the more complicated you will
be inclined to make it and this is also
not just with an entrepreneurship but
even in writing I mean you have someone
like I think Khaled Hosseini and I'm
pronouncing his name correctly but who
wrote The Kite Runner who was a I
believe a a full-time position at the
time so he had to use tiny chunks of
time here and there to really focus it
was not an option not to focus because
his time was so limited so it can be a
very useful forcing function and the
reason I mentioned that is that a lot of
people who there are many people myself
included I do this all the time too so
it's it's a matter of conditioning
yourself to use this lens but it's it's
very easy to look at a perceived lack of
time as a weakness but if you view it
instead as a forcing function where when
you focus you have to focus you cannot
get away with checking social media
every five minutes and get anything done
then it can be a real asset so you guys
were using what nights weekends when we
when were you actually finding the time
or was it in separate chunks so first
thing we said is let's apply the twenty
eighty to the classes so what are the
things that we actually have to do to
get you know still get our good grades
but uh but not necessarily spent a
hundred percent of the time that
normally people would spend and then the
time that was opened by that then say no
we have this little bit of time what can
we do for the business and that 20 to
produce the eighty percent of the
results and then note on on the 28th is
sometimes so it's really easy to
identify say when you're not doing the
twenty of the eighty say with social
media or with wasting your time but
often it's even harder to identify it
when you're doing in things that seem
productive right when you're saying okay
I'm going to spend you spend four hours
trying to get the the image perfect
well it's that that often is just as bad
as spending those four hours on social
media so it's harder to identify that
and always be be aware of like and one
one big concept or one big book that
that has helped us fight through that
has been the the one thing by Gary Kelly
he's actually Austin Gary Kelly yeah
yeah another local yeah it's new huge
huge real-estate Empire for people who
don't know the name yeah
gigantic you know so we we used that
concept and we combined the carving out
of the classes versus that carving out
of the business that carving out that
80% that doesn't make much of a
difference and that's what we made time
for it and we had we had time I mean we
do work hard we worked pretty much all
day all day of the we every day of the
week but we do have time for leisure to
you know space out the mind and do
things that we also find fun too two
quick notes on that and then we're going
to come back to introducing new products
so I wanted to hit the manufacturing and
then we we've we've taken a slight side
road not a not a not a divergence
because it's all convergence but the two
things I want to mention are number one
that buzz it's really just one thing and
that is that the less people are
thinking of themselves wait a second
this is the 4-hour workweek guy and
these two just said they work all the
time how does he reconciled us to it's
actually really easy because the the
title is more of a metaphor and the case
studies within the book even are very
very very different and the the
objective is to maximize your practical
output per hour and then if you want to
build say a business that covers your
expenses and helps you put your kids
through school and then you spend the
rest of your time exploring other
passions that's one path if you want to
build like you guys are doing right now
and eat figure 9 figure business that is
another path right but the tools you
would use 80/20 Pareto etc are all it's
the same toolkit applied to a different
project
so products you started not with one you
started with three and how did you then
go from the initial three to expanding
and was that always the plan
so initially the panelists solve our own
issue then it was getting this there's
partners into the market but what
happened is those people kept coming
back to us and saying okay so cool I
have these products what else I'm still
getting back in and this in this other
area in my life or do you have a
solution for this or I'm this solves my
lower back pain but what about my upper
back pain so started listening to that
as much as we could and starting seeing
how can we help our customers for longer
and and and for move with more things
again really CS approach data-driven
started understanding with researching a
lot of the key word what are the best
selling partners in terms back pain how
can we add value created a list of of
candidate products that we were going to
launch and said we're going to launch
another 22 onto the market how did okay
so your data-driven how did you decide
in 22 it was what we was a combination
of what we thought we could get out of
payment terms from our suppliers versus
the profits that we had originally made
because we were reinvesting 100% of
everything got and so for growth
purposes you could have the max number
you could afford to launch based on the
assumptions you had which were grounded
in your data you had thus far yes 22 if
you watched 30 you were really kind of
playing more Russian roulette with
potential finances potentially going to
run out of stock yeah can I ask a
question are there any areas of the
decision-making on the products where
emotion intervenes you guys seem like
you're naturally very good at applying
rules and discipline but do you ever
just say I just really love this product
or do you not allow that when you're
making the decisions we think we don't
allow it I don't worry
yeah but emotion is always there yeah we
try to we try to make it as numerical as
possible and as rational but there's
always something yeah there's no
perfection but but yeah we decided to
launch the 2022 is also gonna be
interesting because it was gonna force
us to do it in a system
way we only had a few hours a week from
her from our school and we would need to
develop 22 parts so everything needed to
be formulaic and systematic so that was
when we we started laying the groundwork
for the systems that we currently have
in place for the big launch that we'll
talk about after the 120 so yeah that's
how we selected the products and then
replicate it the same the same cycle
that we've done for those initial first
and three to those 22 is what are the
other competitors doing what are they
doing wrong what are they doing right
what are the people want and how can we
get it all together in a single product
and how can we get it to market as
quickly as possible so we set ourselves
a deadline of three months from the
point we decided to the point that's
gonna be selling and that includes the
sipping three months for 22 products
yeah and then includes shipping by sea
which is a month to Europe and and about
a months to manufacture so we only had a
month to actually get it all ready to
work okay so the two you guys clearly
very smart you're you're very analytical
and just before I forget a quick pause
if you guys find yourselves getting
really fatigued and more and down by the
business you should launch something
just for shits and giggles seriously
I've done that just to like resuscitate
my enthusiasm so that for instance you
can I'm just envisioning in my head you
could have some type of ridiculous like
rainbow unicorn slippers that you
engineered every time someone buys one
your product that's like customers also
buy just to inject a little bit of fun
it could be worth it but he where was I
going with that I got off track with
Signature Series see you you guys well
educated smart you're sort of in your
professional sports prime in a way right
like you guys have a lot of energetic
resources and if you have to just live
on like Red Bull and ramen you can do
that but that sounds like a test you
guys can't do by yourselves and it also
sounds like a test that would be very
hard to script because I mean God forbid
you're scripting the copy I could see
some really ridiculous stuff coming out
give that ideas yeah
so dude do you have did you have and do
you have help and if so what does that
look like okay so we we scale the team
originally I don't know if you guys are
familiar with Dartmouth but it's pretty
much a little town in the middle of snow
yeah so there's really not much room to
hire full-time people besides that we
were running like we were still in
school so we went to platform like up
work and there's many up like them out
there I started looking for freelancers
that would help us execute some of these
tasks and we actually were surprised to
find is the the quality and the level of
the people in those platforms they're
very very smart people very educated you
mentioned up work any others that really
come to mind for you for the most part
we use up work there's freelancer.com
free up but we've mostly stuck with
upward like that work okay um so so we
we were completely surprised by the
quality and the level of specialty of
the people on those platforms and we
started hiring remote people that would
dedicate one or two hours of their day
they usually had other clients as well
that would do a very specific task so
say a copywriting we would hire a
copywriter in each of the languages
here's our 20-point checklist right
follow this 14 SOPs or improve it
created the SOPs and SOP yes it a
standard operating procedures a fancy
word is checklist and are you
communicating with them the email slack
something else created a slack for all
of us everyone's in there um
facilitates a lot of the things and
that's how we started running those
processes and and now much like with the
manufacturers on any job board or
freelancer community there are going to
be some amazing people and they're also
going to be some clowns so how do you
guys qualify or disqualify people really
quickly yeah great question that's our
biggest question yeah that's a very big
questions to which we don't have a full
answer but it's our most pressing
question we took a similar approach to
the copywriting initially so same as
those first 30 days try to do as much
research as possible looking at
companies who do hiring and especially
the selection part correctly so we a
really good book is the who interview
that yeah that is yeah who is a great
it's a very really gross it's basically
a streamlined shorter version of top
grading exactly which a lot of my
startups which are venture backed but
same same I mean the best of them still
operate with very similar metrics and
mentality yeah-hoo-hoo is a very good
book another one called work rules which
is by Laszlo Bock it's on Google's
inside how they apply how they go about
hiring and selecting candidates and and
some other really interesting thoughts
my whole library at home I have run ten
books I think just dedicated to hiring
and and selecting people so it's very
important issue so what have you found
the to be I know you don't have a
perfect answer yeah maybe that doesn't
exist but what are things you have
implemented that you found helpful for
qualifying its qualifying people quickly
absolutely so based on the research
we've done similar processes with the
20-point copywriting formula with
interviewing we found a few key
principles which are the main ones are
structured interviewing is bad so if you
incorporate some structure to your
interviewing process that will give you
on average better results over the long
run so on what structured interviewing
means you have a multi-step process so
that can mean a phone screen and then in
a cultural interview where you assess
the culture and then a reference call
and then maybe a work sample and who
does a good job of that's one example
but they provide that structure yes
exactly
we actually base ourselves of the
process in who so that's a key principle
and also having the interview questions
predefined because otherwise what happen
the candidates tell their own story and
cater it to what you want to hear and
our echo chambers in the sense of what
you've told them about the position or
what they read on the job description
well it also makes it very difficult to
compare Canada to Canada if you have
different exact interviews exactly so
having those questions predefined and
then there are certain questions for the
areas you want to assess which are most
likely to yield a better assessment than
other questions having those predefined
and also stating beforehand this is what
a good answer looks like this is what a
bad answer looks like this is what a
mediocre answer look like that is very
helpful in getting some rigor into the
into the selection process to avoid just
going for people who you like who you
relate with who have similar backgrounds
than you etc secondly we found that
reference calls and heavy referencing so
that means at least probably three to
four references and then asking those
references to provide another reference
which is very important because of
course people who job applicants who
provide your references are banking on
the fact that those references are going
to give positive reviews yeah questions
to try correct for that as well we would
be an example of that so for example we
had a candidate were that we were trying
to test out for that for his or her work
ethic
um and because obviously if you if you
ask somebody do work hard they always
see they're always gonna say yes and
regards while you ask that question so
the best way is to see how others assess
their work ethic but if they're counting
on the reference to give a good
reference that they won't tell you yeah
he has a you know he of course he has a
good work ethic so the way we've we've
done a couple we obviously won't say all
the tricks but one of the tricks is that
we we go up to the reference and say
look to the candidate a little column
Jim hey look Jim said sometimes he
struggles to stay motivated and and to
work really long nights what are your
thoughts on that which Jim is not said
right and so that
so then so then you based on their
reaction because if somebody is really
really hard-working they'll say what Jim
that has range it's weird
they've they've always been you know
they'll react that way whereas if
they're actually not yeah Jim's been
struggling but look it's just cuz the
bosses and they'll come up with a reason
to kind of save him yeah but then it
clearly shows those are a few ways that
you can kind of angle the question yeah
another one which friend of mine told me
I thought was quite clever which applies
in the US and there's some legal
restrictions and guidelines around this
kind of thing because many people will
be terrified to say anything that might
jeopardize the person's hiring for legal
reasons and so one way to get around
that is to if you if you ensure that you
send people and email so you don't get
them on the phone you either leave a
voicemail or send them an email which is
I'm interviewing so-and-so for potential
position I would love to know how much
you would recommend them no need to
reply unless it is like an 8 or higher
right and then they have plausible
deniability and they can always say I
never got it yeah but and you have to
make sure you have a sample size that's
significant enough or you know that
these people are in contact so that that
works and you know you don't get a false
negative if that makes sense but that
would be another approach in terms of
quick vetting I'll give one one more up
another tactic that was shared with with
me by a friend who's many multiple time
near Times bestselling author and runs a
number of businesses and hires a lot of
contractors and what he'll do is he'll
have some type of he'll start with a
work test right he'll start with a test
of some type that has a very fast
turnaround it's like 48 hours this needs
to be done and they the first step is
very often to respond with certain types
of information but at the very end of
the work task it will say do not reply
via message or email I call this phone
number and leave a message with your
answer and it's it's it has to be in a
larger context that it's easy to miss
and he's testing for
tension to detail and doing that
sometime that's basically his first
hurdle and and it immediately screens
out 99% of the people who do just do not
pay attention alright so how many how
many folks do you have helping you at
the moment so we use the freelancer
approach by the way one last thing I
want to add to that work samples are the
biggest indicator to job success so if
you can make somebody end up work clear
way a easy way to to filter people and
say hey this is what I need to do is do
is a shorter version of whatever they
need to do
easiest way there are three people but
anyway really important know that
there's some really good resources on
YouTube I think it's why company
Combinator why another wine Combinator
and Stanford or Y Combinator taught a
class at Stanford and there is some
really good lectures there on team
building there's one with Vinod Khosla
from Khosla Ventures he's great on
hiring he believes hiring is the one
thing to to scale and there's another
lecture with I think his name is Ben
Silbermann Silverman of Pinterest off
Pinterest and the two stripe co-founders
he like all some brothers yeah and they
also talked about hiring team building
incredible value right there so I
recommend that to anyone who's looking
to hire or vet people great it's been of
great value yeah that's that's a
tremendous series of classes I think
they may have made some of them into
podcasts as well so people yeah check in
Albany I'll put all these in the show
notes for everybody so you you're saying
that so I was saying yeah so we started
hiring freelancers all from from the
college dorm insane to work out through
those little pieces of the system
compiled everything in an excel sheet
and everyone knew what needed to be done
and within a month there's 22 products
we're live and we've kept those people
and place they're about 26 right now
they're 26 freelancers deal answers some
of which we only use say on an on demand
basis so we don't have a copywriter
sitting along doing copy all day
it's just when we launch any product
they might come in but there's about 12
to 14 that are pretty much every day
running the day-to-day system is up
of our company so that's how we launched
the 22 products they were really
successful as soon as they they hit the
market we started iterating on them and
still to this day we iterate on them and
try to make them better I have constant
talks about how can we improve those 22
and took a step back and said by then we
were already on track to the eight
figures of about the 10 million and we
said look we've done something right
we've scaled it up and and and we
started learning a bit more about how
the bigger market and the consumer
packed goods and just packaged screw
some dinner worked and so Ben and I
researched into how CPG companies we're
doing their development again
acknowledging that our keys key
component of successful is our ability
to use data as the development guy
Atlanta the North Star and CPG 4 focuses
consumer packaged goods which can range
from protein bars to shampoo shampoo to
just about it I think think Procter &
Gamble or any of these large large
brands exactly so we start learning how
they were doing a lot of the development
not any in specific just in general but
they were doing a lot of the product
development it was usually not very
data-driven they would they would have
focus groups that were not statistically
significant and there was not real
consumer behavior or purchasing intent
and and they really didn't and the
reason why we discovered they weren't
really putting a lot of effort into the
development is because they have all the
leverage from all the household brands
that they used then to push new parts
into the market and eventually hopefully
become a household brand so they have a
lot of leverage into the distributors
and the retailers so there's no
incentive there but the digital arrow is
allowing us to change that and and
that's what we've been doing with
supporting back without really knowing
it is going straight to the customer and
saying look we can make it better what
can we do better about this product and
and how can we make that make it better
part for you so we said can we replicate
that approach across the bigger the
bigger industries such as a beauty and
skincare and and the pet supplies and
pet food and baby and even nutrition so
so Ben and I said look if we want to get
to that point we always
need to have people that have been there
done that service professors come in and
tell us how to scale to that point so
that's when we that's when he kind of
decided to take a big turn in life and
and and put the studies in hold and come
here to Austin and build what we call
the exact team or are the people above
above us even that'll help us scale to
that to that portion and one thing that
folks might not realize and I didn't
know this until I actually got to Austin
is that some of the best CPG
entrepreneurs and investors in the
country maybe in the world are here in
Austin and a lot of that is thanks to a
university known as Whole Foods because
the the alumni and former execs and so
on and serial entrepreneurs who've built
say consumables companies right whether
that's like epic bar or deep Eddie vodka
or whatever you might find tend to stay
in the area and I see this very dense
network of people who've really
understand how to build CPG companies
whether that's cold brew coffee or tina
has a shampoo or her gluten-free
tortillas or foam link there there are
many many examples I had no idea before
I got here are you guys looking to build
or buy or both so right meaning yeah
you're looking to build all these brands
which you guys have have shown you can
do are you looking to buy or acquire in
some fashion companies or products how
are you guys thinking about that so we
don't see it as mutually exclusive sure
we are very good at ramping a brand up
from scratch and we've done that and I
doing that many times over now with the
additional products and then creating a
longer-term higher growth curve because
of our product development process et
cetera so acquiring right now at an
early like an early stage brand or
beneath that would fit our portfolio
does not currently justify the premium
we would pay for that right however once
these other brands are also up and at
the same level let's party back and
growing it can it's definitely within
our trajectory to look at other brands
we can bring in that fits strategically
with our current brand portfolio and
then to bring them in to roll them up to
leverage any any complementary products
audiences et cetera so it's definitely
definitely consideration we've been
speaking with other back-pain brands
already for supporting back yeah so it's
within the trajectory from the early
stage it doesn't justify the price
premium mm-hmm then there also I should
say there are options C D and E and so
on not just 100% build or 100% buy yeah
for instance there are almost infinite
number of ways you can structure an
acquisition where you might have not
that you necessarily want to get into
exchanges of equity but you could have
an equity component where you're giving
a piece of the company as opposed to
upfront cash you could avoid that or in
combination with that have very
elaborate earn-out clauses or people are
they're getting paid for their brand but
only after they have been assimilated
and proven that they can transport their
skills and and or perhaps their customer
base and so on to the portfolio products
so there are ways to do it where you can
mitigate against the upfront costs but
it is fascinating world that that we
won't get into but I want to ask you
guys because we're gonna wrap up in just
a little bit here is among other things
why so what I mean by that is a
different way to phrase that would be
what for what I mean by that is you're
growing your you are going to be
hopefully accelerating growth
based on your current enthusiasm for it
which seems very palpable weird you want
this to be in three or five years like
what are you guys trying to do and yeah
and I might I might stress test your
answer a little bit so we'll see what do
you guys try what do you guys try to do
and why is it worth all the time and
energy and so on that you're putting
into it so I'll start with the why I
think I think Ben and I have both really
big Drive for for delivering value and I
know this sounds a bit a bit abstract
but I think the role of an entrepreneur
in the world is to find ways to do
things better or more efficiently and
then try to do that as many times over
with the help of other people so that's
something that's really driving us and
when we find a way to do things better
it's like how can we do more of it and
it becomes almost like a drug into like
okay we found a better way to do better
products and we set direct impact and
the people that were giving them so the
back pain products people go back and
say look it actually helped and when it
becomes too you know the few parts that
we tested in the other industries like
this part is much better than the one I
had and that feels a lot of what we do
now where does that how does that tie
into the company where we want to go is
again all we're doing is replicating
that first initial back pain product
that we're doing it's the same concept
is how can we deliver a better product a
very packaged good to a customer and I
think that the big companies have done
it a specific way and that way is
changing and it's gotten better with
digital so we want been a target group
to become the new I hate the word
conglomerate but the new group of brands
or a new group of or a new accelerator
for products a launch platform for new
and better products for customers around
the world where we actually give them a
voice and that is reflected in the
quality of the parts that they're
getting that's the ultimate vision how
does that look like in terms of size I
have no idea how does that look like in
terms of structure have no idea as long
as our core focus is or the way we lead
our actions is how can we do that
initial value delivery that we proved
with our support
back in our college dorms how can we
deliver that same value many many many
times over so we're doing it 120 times
hopefully we'll do it more and more
times over but obviously it's not just
the one time that you launch it is how
can we iterate as many many many times
over mm-hmm does that answer a bit it
does it does it does I'm curious too I
should have had you in separate rooms
and then a lot of the intrinsic
motivation for may I speak I think both
on math for Santiago and myself comes
from learning and actually going back to
the computer science just solving
problems yeah I think part of I mean I
barely know you guys of course but I
mean part of what seems just I'm using
something very non quantitative right
now which is just like my intuitive
theory of you guys is that you get a
real high from creating the recipe and
seeing if you can replicate yeah yes
like did we get it right
it's the same feeling you get when you
debug a program and it works and like
boom you know I can do the same
operation billion times yeah same thing
yeah yeah it's exactly that and the
growth the personal growth working on
new challenges every day figuring out
solutions to complex problems like
hiring how do we best approach that what
are best practices
how about product development just
constantly learning finding new problems
to solve and even if the problems on a
day-to-day basis breaking them down
making them small solving reverse
engineering mm-hmm yeah it's just
learning from the people that work from
us as well they are so good at what they
do because they have been hyper focused
and hyper specialized that it's almost
like a classroom you know a lot of
people say like hope but then you know
you you're in pause and in school like
how does it feel to not continue to
learn it's completely the opposite we've
continued to learn and it's like having
a teacher work with you every day from
you can learn a lot so that is also a
big driving force of why we want to keep
going who are some of the entrepreneurs
or leaders you guys most look up to or
think about modeling or studying let's
start with you ah you got your face so I
don't know yes you can pick the context
if I if I have to choose one I'll
obviously choose to the Charlie Munger
and Warren Buffett because they're but
if I have you don't know you can choose
as many as you like there's no limit
it depends for what there's there's
people that I that are really good at
the hiring there are people that are
like who our names Vinod Khosla Ben
Silverman paul english co-founder of
kayak brian go back was a local here who
runs skinny pop popcorn and amplified
snack brands yeah that's just there's
Paul Graham Sam Altman sorry for the
other people who didn't mention
acceptance speech so my personal notes
every time I learned something about
people and hiring I added so that it's a
massive list of around I think been out
when fifteen pages who fall tips on
hiring like every note I take every it's
like a personal notebook every time I
learned something about hiring how to
hire better how to manage people better
I added to my list and I constantly
carry that around and there were fifty
plus people people's advice in their
book someday passion for constant
learning come from is that just
intrinsic to who you are did that come
from somewhere external it's just I
think intrinsic constantly wanting to
get better and like being a better self
tomorrow or going to bed at night
knowing I've learned something and I'm a
better person in in what whatever
dimension that maybe then when I woke up
are there any any books or resources you
guys are going through right now
alright either something you just
finished something you're reading or
digesting or thinking about right now or
something you're about to start reading
yeah okay so it's overall on reading and
books the core principle we follow and
we've learned our lesson in that we we
got distracted by a lot of
reading research it's a great way to
procrastinate exactly what you same
thing it's one of those 80 that a that's
a sneaky one it's a sneaky one you feel
like you're doing you're being
productive when in fact you aren't so
taking that into account and limiting
the amount of time you spend learning
from a book or in a classroom or a
course versus executing and actually
getting stuff done that's been a big
learning overall we take the approach of
we try to focus all the books we read
all the courses we take on anything we
can apply within the next 90 days or be
it six months because we want to read
for practicality so otherwise you're
just gonna have to reread it again later
anyway and we do reread a lot of the
books a mistake and I'm very ignorant
and very young but something I've seen a
lot of people do is they read many many
books and then never revisit them so
just from a mathematical perspective
there's also a distribution in the
quality of books and some of the books
you've already read are much higher in
quality and in potential impact than any
book currently on your book list so
rereading that and actually honing in on
on key concepts just normal learning
principles like spacing out repetition
can be much more valuable than reading
another book yeah yeah is there a
particular book than you're reading at
the moment or break no I think it's
called high velocity hiring which is how
do you hire for scale because as we're
approaching alright the next year with
nine figures in prediction that's going
to take a whole different organizational
structure and with a key constraint
being growth in terms of time so from a
personal side we were reading to a raft
of Ellie's books one is the art of
thinking clearly in the art of a good
life hmm which have been roasted the
author's name again wrof wrof to the
belly
yeah it's do B e ll I mm he's from
Switzerland absolutely great books
they teach psychological concepts so a
lot of biases how did you guys choose
those books right because we're talking
about how much time you can chew up and
miss spend on books so selection it's
kind of like hiring people are vetting
people how did you guys end up both
reading those books
it's referrals is how we sourced the
list so we look for people we've admired
that are been successful at that
specific thing and we asked them then we
keep a list and then we categorized them
depending on what problem it solves so
in case of hiring we have like a list of
hires to be having a hiring issue we go
and try to read those so it's basically
mainly we fir I don't remember who refer
it over off to beli that's okay yes some
other process yeah but ultimately a note
on the reading and the learning is the
the ultimate the ultimat teachers
experience is the best way to learn is
experimenting and you can sit down and
read seven books on hiring but you'll
learn way more the time you hire a
person and that it ends up being a
really bad hire so you know you can be a
victim of like thinking paralysis and
sit down and contemplate what are the
different options I can different books
I can read on hiring and that's good to
have some some knowledge ahead of time
but then ultimately take the leap and
and do whatever is it that you're trying
to do and you'll learn way more from the
feedback and reflect on what you did
right and wrong as well yeah it makes me
think of something I was it was imparted
to me by a woman in Kathy Sierra I'm
very smart which was focusing on
just-in-time information instead of just
in case information yeah that's a way to
makes a huge huge difference well this
has been really fun and Len do you have
any any any last questions you'd like to
ask before we wrap up with these these
gents I get one question for the
listeners who are not very mathematical
what advice would you give them if they
wanted to follow your lead
I would say you have an advantage
because you keep it simple
we've been victims of overcomplicating a
lot of things because we we finally over
complicated so you don't really need
math try to understand the world from
from a trend perspective so all that
takes is just read basics on on stats
what ik what is a correlation verses
just a number and what establishes a
correlation but other than that is you
really don't need if it's too
complicated it's Brian not the way
there's very simple ways of doing
everything so you probably have an edge
on that yeah you know one of my friends
Nick Gahan drew as well the cofounders
of ZocDoc very CS quantitative and I
want to say I might be getting this
wrong he's he's been on the podcast as
somebody might be all the to correct me
here but leave you recommended a book
called how to measure anything which is
very helpful for taking fuzzy thinking
and making it more discrete just easier
to examine and which doesn't mean I've
never taken calculus for God's sake so I
have like you know calculate the
hypotenuse oh Jesus I'm about as yeah
about as basic as it gets
but you you don't need a lot you just
need to really get good at measuring
what matters and very few things matter
a lot and you need to be very good at
pausing and checking your assumptions
about other things yeah so guys where
can people if you would like them to
learn more about you or just follow what
you guys are up to if if that's even an
option but for those people like who
knows maybe Ben Silbermann who's been in
one of my books or one of these people
maybe they're listening to the podcast
there I go
maybe I should send a hand wave to these
folks is there any is there any way to
do that so it's Benny talk Benny taco
group B and I TIG oh and you talk oh
yeah okay and I teach oh alright yeah
bent out calm and we are both on
LinkedIn mm-hmm and we pride ourselves
and not having any other social media
outlet out there that is we focused on
growing yeah I think that is a fantastic
policy well thank you guys for taking
the time I know that you have lots of
exciting things coming up so I wish you
well
hey Jim and Elaine thank you for
spending time with us as well thank you
Tim this was fun and to everybody
listening
we all have links to everything all the
books and so on resources up work
the one thing 1680
eight cash cow pros cash will all be
available in the show notes at teamed-up
log forward slash podcast and until next
time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell out and just drop in if your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
Charlotte's Web which makes a CBD oil a
hip extract that has become one of my
go-to tools now I have never really
talked about CBD oil and cannabis has
never really been the plant for me and
only talking about a head but
nonetheless after several nights of
inexplicable insomnia this is about a
urine I just could not get to sleep
saved my life and after other fixes
failed so melatonin and California Poppy
extract better than enough an elite
athlete introduced me to this non
psychoactive extract then BAM problem
solved I had some of the best sleep
had in months now I don't use sleep
based on a daily basis but this has
become part of my toolkit and I hope to
be exploring other applications soon CBD
oil products have exploded in popularity
in the health and wellness of Fitness
world in Charlotte's Web is one of the
top players that offers a broad spectrum
hemp extract with CBD in the form of
oils capsules and topical products
Charlotte's Web products will not get
you high so that maybe that is good news
maybe bad news to you but it does have
some powerful benefits and the
applications and it works with your
body's existing endocannabinoid system
and donating from within like endo vs
exoskeleton princess so endocannabinoid
system works with your body some of the
most common uses are for relief from
everyday stressors call in supporting
restful sleep which is what I most often
use before to bring about a sense of
calm and focus on my friends was for
that CBD is also known for becoming
known for helping athletes to recover
from exercise-induced inflammation
Charlotte's Web him extract has
naturally-occurring terpenes flavonoids
and other valuable hemp compounds at
work synergistically to heighten
positive effects sometimes refer to as
the entourage effect which you guys can
look up making it more complete than a
single compound CBD alternatives or at
least that is what I've been told I do
not know much about CBD alternatives nor
single compound in any case
check it out this stuff is really worked
for me to jump over to CW hemp dot-com
for / Tim CW is in Charlotte's Web
CW Kemp compote / Tim to take a quick
quiz which will determine the best
product for your particular Ames
lifestyle etc and they ship to all 50
states Charlotte's Web are offering
listeners of this podcast 10% off of
their purchase while there are some
exclusions I personally use the extra
strength CBD oils for the extra strength
capsules and you can see what might be a
fit for you on that page
and there is a 30-day risk free
guarantee so why not try not to get 10%
off of your purchase at CW hem comm
forward slash Tim and disclaimer these
statements have not been evaluated by
the Food and Drug Administration this
product is not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any distance enjoy
this episode is brought to you by
peloton which I've been using problem
for about a year now peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you can also do on-demand
which is what I do it will come back to
that so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or
making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute I for
instance have a peloton bike right in my
master bedroom at home and it's one of
the first things I do many mornings I
wake up I meditate for a bit then I
knock out a short 20 minute ride in my
undies hard to do that at the gym take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's really convenient
and has become something that I look
forward to so you have a lot of options
for one if you like you can ride live
with thousands of other riders across
the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip-hop rock and roll or say
low-impact versus high intensity or
interval you can pick the class
structure and style that works for you
and in my case I point like Matt
Wilbur's and I tend to do on-demand and
listen to a lot of and watch many of the
same classes over and over but I'm kind
of promiscuous and also enjoy classes
from a lot of the other instructors they
have peloton an amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
with a whole range of styles and
personalities so you can find what
you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track the performance over time and that
will help I would say catalyze you to
beat your personal bests now that all
sounds good right gamification yadda
yadda yadda I didn't think that it would
work for me or in any way incentivize me
but they really 100% hit the nail on the
head I was very very impressed with how
motivating it was
and work tremendously to keep me pushing
which quite honestly takes a fair amount
I can get quite lazy particularly with
anything that edges on endurance which
is kind of more than five reps of
anything for me so check it out
discover this cutting edge indoor
cycling bike that brings the studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one Hallet
uncom that's o + e peloton PE l OTO
and.com and enter the code Tim all caps
at checkout and get $100 off of
accessories with your policy on bike
purchase so get a great workout of home
anytime you want check it out go to one
peloton calm and use the code Tim to get
started
you
you